hi guys instead of whiskey today I've
got coffee because it's daytime not that
that matters sometimes today I am
watching the Crystal Skull no no I keep
saying that definitely not the Shia
LaBeouf movie today I'm watching The
Dark Crystal and I've lost count at how
many episodes this is I think five I
think this is episode five of Tamra's
never seen but we're gonna we're gonna
scrap the number system from here on out
because I don't want to get to like this
is episode 62 of Tamra's never seen I
think you know what I mean we're just
gonna let that whole thing go gonna let
it go Oh Tanner has never seen huh that
was boring yet impressive so it starts
off with the exposition about the dying
world and the dying leaders and the
dying everything and it's like these are
some like bleak ass puppets but that
being said those puppets were incredible
I grew up knowing about Jim Henson
because of Star Wars and then David
Bowie sadly passed and I finally got to
watching the labyrinth but until this
opening sequence of this movie I did not
realize his power and his glory and he's
like two puppets what like Barack Obama
is two black presidents like he's the
only one and then it was like sometime
in like the five minute mark of this
movie that I was like is it just gonna
be puppets oh my god I really thought
they were gonna be human characters no
puppets this is incredible I'm
officially on board I'm gonna walk right
across my lap you're gonna sit on my lap
oh no you're just passed by so then they
introduced Jen who is the hero of the
story he's the chosen one but he's like
shown and he said and he's got his pipe
and they're like even his pipe can't
give him comforts and was the wrong kind
of pipe obviously
it's a drum joke really tense
I am so impressed with every puppet in
this movie except for Jen
Jen's lifeless face is one thing but
like his voice the voice actor is just
so lifeless I don't know if that's like
they just wanted somebody really like
like the straight man or like they
wanted that to be like maybe that's how
the whole species talks but like it was
just it's weird and sometimes he's like
internally thinking things in his mouth
doesn't move so he's just like this but
Master I'm not ready to go alone
sometimes he talks but his mouth doesn't
move well so it's just like this my
peace pipe doesn't give me comfort maybe
I should fill it with marijuana you know
it's very distracting then you see the
sketches and they're like the rulers of
the land and they've got the main guy
the emperor in the middle and he's dying
and one of them like creepily comes up
to him and he's looks at the other birds
and he's like well he's not dead yet and
I'd really wanted the emperor to like
jump out of bed and pull a Monty Python
and like start singing well you're not
dead yet I can dance and I could sing
but he did not do dead sadly so then the
Emperor does die and he crumbles into
himself like a thousand-year-old corpse
and it's horrifying and it's a seemingly
pointless
I guess it's cuz the Skeksis have been
alive and ruling forever oh yeah and
then you find out later that they're
getting like life blood and life juice
from these other lower peasants peasants
in the community so maybe that's why I
like they he just ran out of lifeblood
and so yeah I don't know why he crumbles
but it's us pretty horrifying pretty
horrifying moment so then they all try
to decide who's gonna be the new Emperor
and there's two candidates
and they just hit a rock a bunch of
times and whoever breaks the rock is the
new emperor I would never be
the shot looks a little different now
sighting to change my batteries whoa
metal yes so my favorite puppets in the
whole movie are these giant crab evil
crabs giant crab evil crabs are my
favorite puppets and they look like
mirelurks from fallout and mirelurks are
horrific and scary like if you've ever
played fallout in here you're like early
levels of playing that game and you
encounter a myra lurk they're pretty
difficult to kill so I felt for Jen a
little bit mostly I was like whatever I
don't care if you die Jen you're
pointless and annoying that's basic but
it was like 50/50 so Jen has to go get a
crystal shard from Aughra agura
Audra agura I don't know but she's like
this really old woman puppet creature
who talks like a dramatic chicken like
she goes up at the end of everything you
want a shard then the Mystics came I'm
annoying sorry for that but you had to
know how she spoke so then Jen meets
Kyra who is like a female version of him
and they touch each other and they start
dream sharing so like something they're
kind can do he's so my dad's been
watching this series and he's been
saying that I shouldn't say the f-word
so much but he's so fucking awkward
sorry dad hey how you doing thanks for
watching
they're like reliving these past dreams
that they've had and she's like seeing
her parents being taken by monsters and
jen is just over here like hahaha I'm
taking a bath what the fuck Jen no one
cares again I'm sorry dad I'm so sorry
also fizzgig is the toto of Dark Crystal
and it's awesome
I'm all about it good for him he's an
adorable little fluff ball there's this
disgusting scene where the Skeksis are
eating and there's so many slurp noises
and it's amazing they're like picking
their teeth with their giant claw
fingers and also they drink like this
oh it's refreshing why is it here it
gets captured and then sings like the
creepy little snow-white that she is and
has all of these animals come and help
her
they watch you go piece of string piece
for you didn't work out as well as I
thought it would so then the end wraps
up pretty quickly he like heals the
crystal and Kyra gets stabbed and she
dies but they bring her back at the end
and the excists are all like crumbling
apart and like all the little creatures
get their lifeblood back and solid I
definitely wasn't impressed with the
part where Jen like heals the crystal
and like puts a little crystal chunk
into the giant crystal hole well like
anyone could have done that it did not
have to be Jen this like boring bland
puppet okay so the story could have been
ramped up a bit it was kind of every
hero story it was a little boring
honestly I'm just so impressed by these
puppets I really want to know how long
it took them to make all these puppets
how long it took to shot like from start
to finish what was the process of making
this movie cuz it's got to be intense
there were thousands of puppets how long
did it take to make one of those Skeksis
like it was crazy it was really cool I
really enjoyed watching that totally 10
out of 10 worth it just to watch the
puppets also saying this as a kid would
have been pretty neat I think I just
think that it was a little underwhelming
story-wise are you a puppet are you
looking for cheese she's looking for
cheese I'm sorry I ate it all so yeah
that was dark crystal pretty weird and
puppet II if you asked me that's what I
would say I was giving this a rating on
Yelp Dark Crystal six and a half out of
ten
very weird and puppeteer Thank You Wendy
for moving the camera just just just
please okay I could not wish to
participate in this video he's feeling
the demand of being a star and honestly
doesn't like your body shaming comments
that you've been posting so this is
actually your fault bye
this is better this is much better this
way